-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Well, it's 2024,
and you know what happens
later this year.
Oh, damn it!
[ Laughter ]
I was going to say the Olympics.
At a campaign rally
in Iowa last week,
former President Trump said
that President Biden
"can't put two sentences
together."
Um, have you heard him talk?
He can put, like, 100 together.
[ Laughter ]
The same rally
in Iowa last week,
former President Trump
said that the Civil War
"could have been negotiated."
That was crazy enough,
but then he said
the Gettysburg Address
could have been an e-mail.
[ Laughter ]
Same rally, Trump also called
on President Biden
to release Capitol rioters
from prison.
And I guess it was
only a matter of time
before he settled on the same
campaign platform as the Joker.
[ Laughter ]
Former UN ambassador Nikki Haley
is facing criticism
after she recently
failed to cite slavery
as the leading cause
of the Civil War.
And not only that, she's facing
a D in social studies.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
when the violence began to
escalate in the Capitol attack,
then President Trump was
"just not interested
in doing more to stop it."
Either that,
or he was exhausted
from everything he had to do
to start it.
[ Laughter ]
When asked yesterday
about reports that she could be
former President Trump's
running mate in 2024,
Republican Congresswoman
Elise Stefanik
said she would be "honored
to serve in any capacity
in a Trump administration."
Well, I'm pretty sure First Lady
is gonna be up for grabs.
[ Laughter ]
Apple announced today
that its Vision Pro headset
will launch next month --
this news first reported
on your hand,
your wrist, your lap,
and, pretty soon, your face.
[ Laughter ]
After their dog recently ate
an envelope filled with $4,000,
a couple in Pennsylvania
was able to recover
$3,500 in cash.
Said their friends,
"You can just Venmo me."
[ Laughter ]
Taco Bell has begun offering
Crunchwrap Supreme
meal kits at Walmart,
which include tortillas,
crunchy tostada shells,
taco seasoning,
and Velveeta cheese sauce.
You can cook it at home,
then take it right out
to your car to eat it.
[ Laughter ]
The largest radio company
in the country
announced over the weekend that
it has filed for bankruptcy.
If you haven't heard about it,
it's because they announced it
on the radio.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Alabama
was arrested recently
after he allegedly
crashed his car
outside of a Bass Pro Shop,
took off his clothes, and jumped
into the store's aquarium.
But I'm not going to make
a joke about that
because it's low-hanging fruit.
Actually...
after he jumped in the water,
it became high-hanging fruit.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Anybody who doesn't get it,
stay after
and we'll, like, do a...
[ Laughter ]
Baze, I think, told me
he drew a diagram.
[ Laughs ]
We should offer more,
like, stay after
if you didn't get
any of the jokes.
[ Laughter ]
Someone over there has got
a very stern face.
Keep them after.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
We'll be the only talk show
with detention.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the CDC has issued
a recall
for more than 11,000 pounds
of ready-to-eat meat products.
11,000 pounds of meat,
or, as it's also known,
in Arby's kid meal.
Well, there we go.
[ Laughter ]
Now you know it's a new year.
We've turned over
a new leaf on Arby's.
That was a monologue,
everybody!